>> CHENG: My name is Sega and this is my colleague
Albert. We are software engineers from iGoogle
JPack team. So today we are going to talk
about iGoogle Developer Portal and the tools.
And the session is basically divided into
two parts. In the first half, I will talk
about the iGoogle Developer Portal which is
basically a gadget dashboard collecting your
gadget usage data. While in the second half
of this session, Albert will talk about a
very powerful tool for writing and developing
gadgets. And after that we will take questions
for Q&A. And in this session we will both
do a quick demo of the new service and also
the new tool. Okay, so before we get started,
I would like to remind you that you can jump
in to the wave of this session. You can see
the notes being taken there, the question
being posted there and you can have live discussions
there. And the link is bit.ly/a598YY. Again
bit.ly/a598YY. Okay, so let's get started.
So here is the outline of today's session.
So first, I will talk about iGoogle Gadgets
and OpenSocial. I believe many of you are
already familiar with this key concepts but
we want to make sure that if, even if you
are new to iGoogle or Gadgets or you are a
total stranger to OpenSocial you can still
follow us in this session. And after that
I will talk about the gadget dashboard which
we also call iGoogle Developer Portal. And
next Albert will talk about OSDE which is
the new development tool for writing and developing
gadgets. Okay, let's start it with iGoogle.
So, what is iGoogle and what can you do with
it? The URL is google.com/ig. So basically,
iGoogle is a personalized homepage where you
can customize to satisfy your information
needs. You can customize the information.
You can customize the tools you need as gadgets
on your page. And of course, you can also
do Google search on the page. You can also
interact with your friends. The Google Talk
is fully integrated with iGoogle's page. So,
iGoogle is basically, as homepage, an entry
point for all your Google service. And from--here's
a screen shot of the iGoogle. As you can see
from the screen shot at the top there's a
search box where you can do Google search
as usual and the rest of the page is basically
composed of several gadgets where you can
get weather information, where you can watch
YouTube videos, where you can post notes,
you can read news or even you can play games
on this page. And from a different perspective,
iGoogle for developer is a distribution channel
for your content, for your app, for your games,
et cetera. You can write your own gadgets
and your own applications and put these gadgets
and applications on iGoogle directory and
for millions of active users to use. So for
now we have hundreds of thousands of gadgets
and the list in our iGoogle directory. And
most importantly you can monetize these gadgets
by putting apps behind them. Okay, thanks.
We will talk about gadgets as you've just
seen from the screenshot. The gadget is just
a bunch of HTML JavaScript application that
can be embedded in webpages and other applications.
So we will still talk about gadgets from two
different perspectives. As a user, gadgets
are no more than application by Google users
like you, Google developers like you that
offer over cool and dynamic content that can
be placed on any page on the web. So the gadgets
are not only limited to iGoogle. As long as
the gadgets are written by standard it can
be run on any website and can be embedded
into any webpage you like. Okay, again here's
a screenshot again. In the middle of the page
this is what we call a YouTube gadget. We
can watch the video inside that gadget. It's
very simple. And as a developers gadgets are
great channels to reach more people with your
content. It's really simple to build, all
you need is an XML file and we will parse
that XML file into a bunch of HTML and JavaScript
codes that we can put on to your page or you
can put on your iGoogle homepage. And as I
said, it can run on multiple sites and it
reaches millions of users worldwide. So next,
we talk about OpenSocial. So far we have been
talking about the gadgets that gather weather
information or that you read the news or that
you post notes on your personal homepage.
OpenSocial is a standard that Google proposed
to support social features that will allow
you to interact with your friends. So basically
it's a--as a user it's nothing more than a
technology that enables you to interact with
your friends through those gadgets. And as
a developer, OpenSocial is basically a set
of APIs that make your gadget social. We want
to make OpenSocial in such a way that once
you develop your gadget in OpenSocial it can
be run on any other website that supported
OpenSocial. So OpenSocial is now supported
by many well-known websites such as iGoogle.
iGoogle itself is an OpenSocial container
that can host any kind of OpenSocial gadget.
We also have Mixi, which is the biggest social
network site in Japan. And we also have LinkedIn,
MySpace, Ning, Hi5, these websites, they all
support OpenSocial. So once you write a gadget
that is consistent with OpenSocial standard,
you can run your gadget on this website without
changing any code. Okay. So OpenSocial basically
is a set of standard and specifications so
it doesn't come with any implementations.
So if you want to create an OpenSocial website
and run OpenSocial gadget, the first thing
you have to do is to create an OpenSocial
container and put it on your website. Now,
we have an open source project that is a reference
implementations of the OpenSocial API applications
which is call Shindig, and it's hosted on
Apache. It supports the following social features
like profiles, relationship, activities, all
you can imagine about interactions with your
friends. We won't go into details of Shindig
today but we strongly suggest that you take
a look at this project if you are about to
start your own OpenSocial website. Okay. So
now you know what iGoogle is and you know
how to write a gadget and you know how put
OpenSocial into your gadget to let your gadget
users interact with their friends and indeed
you have already written several decent gadget
and put it on iGoogle directory. So what's
next? The next thing you would want to know
would be, so how is my gadget being used?
What other page we use? What are the numbers
of user I have? And what are the comments?
What are the feedbacks? What are the ratings
my gadgets have? It's very hard to collect
all these information altogether, so here's
our Gadget Dashboard. The internet makes this
information available, while in Google we
make this information accessible. So we create
a gadget dashboard to connect all your gadget
data and how it is used by your users. So
here is the link to the Gadget Dashboard,
it's code.google.com/igoogle. I'll give you
a quick demo after this. So what is a Gadget
Dashboard? The Gadget Dashboard was launched
last year on November and it is live now.
The goal of this project is that we would
like to provide you an entry point for managing
your gadget you developed and also we will
try to aggregate it, organize the gadget usage
information in one place for you to better
understand how your gadget is being used.
So at the bottom is a screenshot of the Gadget
Dashboard. As you can see from the screenshot
there's a gadget listing here and it contains
the stats of a gadget. We'll come back to
the Gadget Dashboard in the demo later. So,
in summary with Gadget Dashboard, you can–-it
is an entry point for managing your gadget.
You can like submit or remove your gadget
to iGoogle Directory or from the Google Directory
with this dashboard. And also you can view
the usage data of your gadgets such as page
views, unique users, comments, feedbacks or
ratings. Okay, so let me give you
a quick demo. Again, the URL is code.google.com/igoogle.
Once you get on to this page you'll see a
link here to go to the Gadget Dashboard. Let's
take a look. So first it will ask you to log
in with your Google account. So, okay, after
doing them, if this is the first time you're
using Gadget Dashboard, you'll be asked to
accept the terms of the service here and if
you're already have several gadget associated
with your account, we will try to pull out
your URL gadget usage data and populate them
in this page. So now, with this account, since
I don't have any gadget associated with this
account. I have to put my gadget URL here,
like this. So here, I will use the gadget.
I would use the currency converter gadget
to do the demo. Since this gadget is not owned
by me, the Gadget Dashboard will check if
I'm the author of this gadget. If I'm not,
it will send a verification email to the gadget
owner and tell the gadget owner that somebody
else is adding your gadget to his dashboard
and he want to see your gadget usage data.
The Gadget Dashboard first asks me if I will
really add, I would really want to add this
gadget into my dashboard. I'll hit that, okay.
So here, the email is now send to the gadget
owner. So I switch here. Okay, now I come
to back to the dashboard and I can see that
access is granted. So I can see the gadget
usage data here and here is our currency converter.
And as you can see here, we have several columns
collecting your gadgets usage data such as
page views, number of unique users, and comments
worldwide and also the status of this gadget.
If you want to add more gadgets into your
dashboard it's very easy to do this, and you
simply hit the, add gadget to dashboard button
and follow the previous steps. So here, let's
take a closer look at, what do we have here.
So if click in, we have a details page for
each task, such as the graph here that's showing
the history of the traffic here, if you are
Google Analytics user you are probably are
comfortable with this table. And we also have
a heatmap, for your gadgets around the world.
And we also have the country breakdowns here,
something like this. Also, we also collect
all comments from different countries here,
like this. Here you see comments in different
languages since you might not speak other
languages except English, we also integrate
this service with Google Translate like I
have to translate comments into English like
this. Here the comments is immediately translated
into English so that you can understand what
it is about. And last, we have status information
here in the last column in here. It says--oh,
the gadget is already in directory and it
was submitted on July 17, 2008. And we also
give you the option to view this gadget into
directory. So if the gadget is not in the
directory, we would also show the status here.
I'm now submitting it to that directory and
we will give you a button here to let you
submit this gadget to the directory. So, that's
basically the Gadget Dashboard. Let's go back
to the slide. Okay, so having talk about this.
Gadget Dashboard is still dynamic project.
It's still in a very early stage of its development
so we'll be rolling out more and more new
features and adding more metrics into the
dashboard. Soon we'll be rolling out in nationalizing
and localization of the Gadget Dashboard into
different countries and different languages.
And last but not the least, we, in the future,
we will try to analyze your gadget to see
its performance and to do the quality checking,
and that we will actively give you quality
suggestions about your gadgets. So that's
all I have for Gadget Dashboard. Next, Albert
will talk about OpenSocial development environment
which is a very powerful tool for writing
gadgets.
>> CHENG: Many thanks to Sega for his demo
and the ensured action to iGoogle and gadgets.
I'm Albert Cheng, a Software Engineer from
Google Taipei office. And at this moment,
you may want to say, "Hey, Albert stop introduction,
let's see some code." Okay, here we are. This
is a Hello World gadget. It's basically a
HTML file that's comprised with OpenSocial
spec. So you can see the, in the code, that
first line is the correlation of XML and then
the second line module and the module prefs
content, all these are defined in OpenSocial.
And you could put your real gadget content
in HTML in the main body here. Also, you could
also embed your Javascript file here. So this
is a very simple gadget. So, how can you edit
a gadget? Of course, you could always use
any text editor to do that. There are some
other options. iGoogle provides two convenient
online tools. Let's have a look at them. The
first one is called a Google Gadget Editor;
the second one, Gadget Checker. Let me switch
to broader, to quickly demo it all out to
you. Okay, this one, this one's a gadget--Google
Gadget Editor, it helps you to edit a simple
gadget online and it provide some basic features
for you. And then this one, Gadget Checker,
it helps you to verify the basic requirements
of your gadget. So these two tools are convenient
online tools for you but they are good for
simple gadgets. How about if you have a complex
gadget, how can you edit that? So here's the
tool, OSDE. That's a powerful Eclipse plugin
that can help you to edit an OpenSocial gadget.
As most of you already know that Eclipse is
one of the most powerful editor in the world
that can edit like a Java files, XML files,
and the Javascript files, et cetera. So with
that, in addition OSDE provides some Wizards
and tools to help you to edit OpenSocial code.
And once you are ready with your code, you
may want to test your gadget. This is always
a difficult part for most developers. OSDE
will help you to easily test your gadget.
It provides two ways to test your gadget.
The first one is you could test it locally
as an OpenSocial container which is called
Shindig. The other option is you have--it
helps you to test it against a production
online container. Right now, OSDE only supports
iGoogle at this moment. We are planning to
support more containers in the future. And
also when you test your gadget online, you
will need to host your--all of your gadget
files somewhere in the Internet. This tool
will help you to easily complete its goal
to host all of your files. Okay, that's a
quick introduction of OSDE. Let's see some
of the background. It's an OSDE, it's an open
source project hosted at code.google.com.
Its license is Apache 2, so that means everybody
could contribute and use it. We recently launched
the version 0.9 this month. And--next, the
contributors--the core contributors, I have
to introduce them. The first one is Yoichiro
Tanaka. He is actually the founder of this
project. He works at Mixi from Japan as a
tech lead. So, Yoichiro could you just wave
your hand? Okay, thanks. And Albert Cheng,
that's me. And we have some other contributors
Do'phin, Sega, and Ching-Yi Chan and et cetera.
Okay, now let's look at some of the demo to
let you know the power of OSDE. Let's switch
to, okay, here. Let me start my Eclipse. Just
wait for a few seconds. Okay, let me say,
type something here to make sure the environment
is okay, because we had some difficulties
at the start of this session. Okay, it looks
fine, WAN IP is adjusted. Start the local
Apache Shindig. That's in OpenSocial container.
Okay, first of all, let's demo a quick Hello
World Gadget from scratch. So, let's start
a new project. Click on OpenSocial. Click
on, next. And create a project name, say Google
io1. Click on, next. And then provide some
basic information here, like the gadget name,
the title, your email address, and then the
feature. We'll just take the default menus
here, and then click on next. There are some
views, like an OpenSocial defines, like canvass
view. Canvass view means the bigger view of
a gadget and the home view means the small
view of the gadget. So, here I'm going to
just use the canvass view for demo and then
choose HTML type. Click on finish. Okay, and
then this tool will quickly help you to create
an OpenSocial project. Let me see what we
have here. We have a gadget file. With this
Wizard, the OSDE tool, you could edit the
basic information, like attributes, features,
and et cetera. You could edit the contents.
Like you could edit the canvass content or
add some more new content here. Look here
for your internationalization. You can add
a new language to your gadget here, user preference
and of course most of you may want to just
edit the source code directory. You could
always scroll out here, source file. Okay,
once you're ready with your code. You want
to test it. You could test it locally. I'm
going to show you first how to test locally;
just one application locally and just accept
the default values. Okay. It will open a browser
and that's the--what you see for this gadget.
So, that's quite easy for you to quickly to
repair a gadget. And then the second way to
test it, it's a--you could test it online
against a production container. So, right
now we support iGoogle. Just click on iGoogle
to review gadget. For testing that, of course
you need a Google account. Let me type the
project name. I'm typing my Google account.
Just click on, OK. There are some notes here.
When you test it online the updates of your
Gadget files may not be reflected instantly.
You may need to wait for few hours but here
it should be okay. Let us try that. And also
wait for a few seconds. Okay, so you can see,
this is the gadget that you will see on the
real iGoogle server. Okay, so that's a simple
gadget. I'm going to demo a more complex gadget
for you. So let's clean out everything here.
Let's have another project. Okay, do the same
thing. Click on OpenSocial project. Click
on, next. Give it another project name, Google
io2. Click on next. Okay, yeah, we'll just
accept the same thing here. Click on, next.
At the last step, I'm going to show you a--listen
we, we're going to help you to like create
external Java file automatically for you.
So, you don't need--if you don't want to embed
your Javascript file in the gadget XML file.
You could always have an external Javascript
file. So this could help you to do that and
also it will help you to generate some simple
code like this one. I choose to generate a
code for fetching the list of your friends.
Okay, I'm going to do the same thing for the
home view. Okay, here. Okay, it's done. Yeah,
okay let's see what we have right now. We
have two Javascript files, canvassed top JS
and the home top JS, these are automatically
generated for you. And when you run your gadget,
all the Javascript files here will be automatically
called. Okay, lets go back to look at the
gadget file, the source code. So you could
see there's a one function called the Fetch
People it's automatically could edit for you.
Okay, now let's assume you're ready with this
complex schedule. You want to test it. For
testing the scheduler is a tricky part. You
need to have a, you need to have some friends
for your account to test it. So this tool
will help you to do that. If you--we go down
here, there's a tab called, The People. It
shows that there are four data in a local
Shindig database. These are automatically
created for you so that you could test them
with this mock data. Usually when you start
using OSDE, you could click on here, OSDE,
and then choose, Create Simple Data in Shindig.
It will automatically create this mock data
for you. And the--let's locate some more data
here. If you click on anyone of them, it could
edit the basic information for each person,
like basic information, or you could even
edit the relationship here. So for this person
can write though, he had his three friends
John, Jane and George. So these are all mock
data in your local database. Besides that,
you could also have some activities of the
data. Applications I can say that because
we are running out of time I'm going to skip
some of the demo here, I will just quickly
show you how this schedule looks like when
you run the, run the local Shindig container.
So lets just run it. Click on OSDE, choose
wrong application locally and you could choose
which view you want to test and which owner
you are right now. Assume we are currently
with in the viewer language country and there
are some other applications like the second
ones. If you click on this pattern it will
have you to measure that gauge of performance
for you. So that's quite pretty good. It helps
you to detect some parts in your code it will
tell you which part you could improve to have
better performance. I'm going to skip this
part. I will just quickly locate the basic
features here. Click on, OK. So this is how
the gadget looks like against your local Shindig.
If you click on this button it will go fetch
to your local database and list all of your
friends here. So that's it. And finally, I'm
going to demo against the iGoogle with this
compact gadget. Usually when you want to test
a gadget online against the production server
you need to first host your gadget file online.
So this one, this function will easily help
you to do a lot of host gadget on iGoogle.
Okay, project name, google io2 we just log-in.
So I'm going to use the previous Google account
session. Click on, OK. This tool will silently
and automatically host all of your gadget
files. Actually, three of them host all of
it, the files online somewhere on iGoogle
server. Okay, it's done and the next step,
the next one is you could edit schedule to
your iGoogle homepage. I assume everybody
here has an iGoogle homepage. So quite easy
just make sure it's the URL you want and then
click on, OK. You do everything that they
can and you will see this page, just click
on, edit now. This page which you just created
will be edit to your iGoogle page. So, and
of course, you could go back to your iGoogle
home to see how the schedule looks like in
a real iGoogle page. But you could always
test the--you may want to just test the schedule.
You don't want to see all the other gauges
of your account. So that's another option
here. Okay, let's--okay, let me go back here.
You could always come back here. This is how
the schedule looks like in your iGoogle homepage.
If you click on this button it'll fetch the
real friends of your Google account. So this
one's you, the other four are your friends.
Okay, once you are ready with your gadget,
you may want to share your gadget with all
the people in the world. So the other one
easy feature for you, you could click on publish
schedule. Make sure this is, it's the URL
which you just created. Click on, OK. Then
after you click on the beneath button then
it's done. Your gadget will be shared by all
the people in the world. So it's quite easy.
I think the most difficult part is you need
to read through the license agreement here.
Yeah that's the--it has the most of the time
anyway. So let's click on somewhere beneath
here. Okay, congratulations your gadget has
been successively submitted and then you could
follow the instructions here to tell your
friends, share your gadget with all the people
in the world. And the--oh, I have a few minutes
so, actually a lot of powerful features in
this tool. With limited time, I can only show
some of them. Like the delete gadget, you
could always manage other files which you
could edit online and then host it on iGoogle.
So like this one. If you don't want your gadget
you could just delete them from iGoogle. Okay.
So that's it. So, yeah that's all about--yeah,
that's all about my demo. I'm going to hand
it over back to Sega because we are close
to lunch time. So I need to skip some of the
demo. If you are interested, you are welcome
to ask me questions later or talk to me later
offline. Thank you.
>> CHENG: Okay, so here are some OSDE references.
You might be interested in taking a look at.
We have OSDE homepage. We have our user guide.
We also have a roadmap for OSDE on the website.
So please take a look at it. Okay, so in the
past, writing a gadget might be a really painful
process for many of you. You have to set up
your own testing environment. You have to
pick your own editor for writing the gadget
and once you manage to complete your gadget,
it's even harder to manage it. So today we
develop a very powerful development tool for
you to use to write your gadgets. And we also
give you a gadget dashboard that put together
all your gadget users data so you can get
a big picture of how people use your gadget.
So again, the gadget dashboard, the link is
code.google.com/igoogle and next OSDE, we
strongly encourage you to take a look, give
it a try and tell us what do you think. So
that's all we have for today. Thanks for your
attention. Okay, so next, we will take questions
from the audience and both from the web. So,
if you have any question please step up to
the mic.
>> Is there any way, you know, your program,
you know, can detect the list (ph) or weight
because this depends on users screen size.
And we can refresh, you know, the gadget in
case I have some, you know, picture or whatever,
I need to re-adjust. You can tell the only
way you define the list (ph) is the percentage.
However is there any way, you know, you can
know the list (ph)? The users weight, you
know, to gauge the list (ph) when you turn
on the iGoogle. Then I can re-adjust, you
know, my weight with this gadget.
>> CHENG: You mean in OSDE or generally in
iGoogle?
>> Generally, yeah, on the program itself.
>> CHENG: iGoogle has a support, some basic
features for detecting the screen size of
your gadget, is that what you want?
>> No, I mean. I need to know when the user
is using your gadget and because they have
different size or a screen.
>> CHENG: Yes.
>> So is there anyway I can tell the users
screen size and I mean, before from whatever,
and then I can refresh my gadget. Because
it depends on I have some table display on
the gadget and the user for example, if your
nearest small screen like a netbooks size.
>> CHENG: Yes.
>> And I need to do re-adjust my table and
make it this square. I don't want to scroll
the up and down and you know, left and right.
You know what I mean?
>> CHENG: I see. So the question is, is there
a way an iGoogle could automatically detect
the clients screen size and then generate
a gadget according to the size?
>> Yes.
>> CHENG: Okay. Yes, we do have some features
to do that. But it might not be powerful enough,
but for example it could detect where you
have some JavaScript and the current size
could detect the client window size and then
it will send back the information. Once we
have a lot we might be able to adjust that.
For example, adjust the number of columns
in the window like by default we have a three
columns...
>> Yes.
>> CHENG: ...to put all of your gadgets. If
your screen is small you might have to adjust--change
it to like two columns. But it's a feature
I'm not sure, unless you're in experiment
right now, so you might not be notice of a
lot because maybe it's still in experiment.
>> Okay.
>> CHENG: So, we do have some basic features
like this.
>> Okay.
>> CHENG: Okay, I hope that answer your question.
Thanks.
>> I just have a question about monetization.
In your existing terms right now, if I understand
it correctly, it's quite restrictive about
actually selling a gadget. I'm just wondering
what your thoughts are on that.
>> CHENG: Can you say that again?
>> In terms of monetization...
>> CHENG: Uh-huh.
>> In your terms right now, it's quite restrictive
about the ability to sell a gadget. You can
sell a feed that comes through it, things
like that, if I'm understanding it correctly.
I'm just wondering what the...
>> CHENG: What the monetization is? Or how...
>> What's Googles' stance on actually providing
a marketplace so you can sell...
>> CHENG: Sell a gadget?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So you can earn some money
to keep building gadgets.
>> CHENG: Uh-huh. Oh, I see. So, well basically
the business model of Google is to put ads
beside your gadget. So basically we don't
have that mechanism for you to like auction
your gadget or sell your gadget on the marketplace.
>> It's not so much having--providing a mechanism,
but your terms are actually restricted. You
don't allow it.
>> CHENG: I don't think so.
>> Okay.
>> CHENG: Uh-huh.
>> We can take this off, I'll show you the
line. The second thing is, and I noticed this
a lot on comments on gadgets, reliability
seems to be a real problem. Things are up
and down quite a bit. I'm just wondering what
your take is
on that.
>> CHENG: Maybe we can talk about that offline.
Okay?
>> Okay.
>> CHENG: Uh-huh.
>> I'll see you in a few minutes. Thanks.
>> CHENG: Okay, no more question? Okay, thank
you.